jean-françois vidéo après avoir été le
le gourou du baba dans les années 70
c'est le pape du techno dans les années
80 tandis ou maintenant georges plus de
caricatures sané ou maintenant voilà en
éclats c'est déjà pas mal
déjà pas mal et les années soixante dix
on a vu ce qu'elles ont été les années
80 qui nous avait dit qu'elle serait
technologique vigoureuse dès les années
90 sa lettre comment
il faut réfléchir un petit peu là dessus
je pense que parce qu'un roc j'espère
jeudi vers quelles vont-être myrick oui
ouverte
et
exploratrice ans le moba m'énerve parce
que ça t'a énervé oui en même temps non
mais moi oui ça m'énerve parce que en
fait n'était pas celui n'est pas coutume
et et des feuilles de marijuana en
couverture de thon jaune mais c'était
lui alors je vais mettre d'accord sur le
problème
ouais c'est pas le problème des bottes
baba s'est passé dans les moeurs
oui ce qui est passé dans les moeurs et
passeur et meurtre c'est plus drôle
d'actuels ou
il faut pas se méprendre
pas par les années 90 il ya qu à
l'entente numéro soir non je le regrette
bien en parler oui mais justement ce
rapport
on a senti le
besoin dix ans les mureaux sont arrivés
bon donc il fallait bien trouver une
solution pour ramasser
la pensée concentre l époque se
concentrent d'époque tafer deux livres
qui étaient vachement bien c'est
déclasser les années blanches qui ont
été à l'époque le premier s'est plutôt
bien vendu
est ce le second en moins bien parce
qu'il était un peu déprimant ouais c'est
aussi l'excellent blanche ouais mais
qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu ne crois
pas en lire en ce moment après tout le
monde mais ça c'est une forme de
bouquins ennemis avec l'ado vous donner
tous actuelle est ce que les soirs de
bouclage et un peu de coke et rhodes ou
alors est ce que vous buvez des cafés
que c'est devenu un journal rangés comme
paris match
c'est à dire que j'aimerais mathieu a
manqué de classe et non celle reçue que
la houppe c'est trop cher pour ce que
c'était mais pas trop longtemps pour
actuelle paraît un peu du tout parce que
c'était on est paysan mouais pas pour
actuelle parce que c'est donc on a
remballé tout ça
c'est vrai que
cette camus est quoi ce come back aux
rouges et du café les quartz tour numéro
je veux dire tu vas pas un défi on
essaie de mettre dans une boîte rien au
monde et on est déjà dans une volte dans
une toute petite boîte
ici donc non mais
on a pensé que c'était pas d'une sortie
exceptionnelle tu en sais quelque chose
qui allait souvent se reconstituer qui
prend donc sur équiperont la seule voie
c'est quand je me suis des vieilles
tchétchénie pas qu'ils aient ou non mais
on est là on parle franchement on va
travailler très franchement c'est sur un
terrain prendront bien sombre quand on
est la porte d'autres là dessus on pense
guère montant jamais été prod au fond
n'a été pour les expériences et on
continue à être pour l'expérience très
bien mais
deux expériences ou d'autres d'eau déjà
pris de l'ecstasy par exemple ouais
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'étais pas mal
vu les saf et une nuits pas mal hein ça
fait n'est pas mal alors serge toubiana
jean françois bizot nous nous expliquait
il ya un instant que certains soirs de
bouclage une époque est désormais
révolue
chez actuelle on prenait certaines
substances pour terminer le bouclage est
ce qu aux cahiers du cinéma ça ça existe
ça nourrit et du café il ya que du café
du champagne et du champagne c'est du
sujet dans les balustrades d'abord le
café et le champagne après et l'ecstasy
vous jamais et valentina tu as déjà
essayé de prendre de l'ecstasy non oui
ça t'a plu qu'est ce que ça t'a fait
faut que j'essaye à oui on aime tout le
monde il parle c'est vrai et oui et ça
dure combien de temps on aime les gens
pendant combien de temps
pendant tout vie pendant toute une vie
oui mais ces formulaires et jill did you
have had sera ecstasy what was urfer
ling ao did you feel it you never die
alone des déplace à un capot
cette fois le monde d'accord lors des
émeutes du 8 mai à la halle aux
amabilités bail du poulet à 1000
balzarini devenu can get groupe tollitte
noor amin as sidra et fuel extreme
personnes il ne faut l'avouer les boîtes
en train de lancer une mode encore grâce
à la télévision d'air 110e ou va
relancer l'ecstasy non c'est de tournai
de manifestants ne t'a pas un besoin
profond un besoin profond de sa voix un
de savoir 2 d'amour et vous il va être
qu'elle vous prenez quoi quand vous
voulez comme ça vous retrouver dans un
état un petit peu différent et bien je
ne peux pas me permets de la musique et
ne permet pas de se retrouver dans un
état différent que la netteté la
précision quand il s'agit de lire de la
musique
oui mais quand vous les nations du
pardon les jours où vous lisez pas de
musée eh bien je me retrouve dans un
unique tae
si vous voulez d'euphorie parce que la
musique vous donne cet état et vous avez
besoin de rien moi j'ai besoin de la
visite un peu de champagne non ça fait
plus chic des fois mais enfin je dois
dire que peut-être en club champagne et
toutes les petites sociétés mais votre
copain gauthier vous a jamais proposé
des trucs un peu un peu bizarre non il a
proposé des joints quand même sûrement
continent il a proposé vraiment décennie
extraordinaire tenue formidable oui mais
c'est tout je savais que jean paul
vettier c'était vraiment couturier de
l'an 2000 était capable de faire des
choses classiques bien entendu est
vraiment c'est un ballon très l'armée
laissez pas de nom non vraiment dans sa
maison il ya une ambiance digne d'être
extraordinaire où il très scène sportive
l'artiste qu'elle a voulu qu'on a voulu
montrer actuelle regarde alors
il s'appelle andré scaling et les
yougoslaves et il fait de l'art capote
alors la semaine dernière on a souhaité
faire rattraper cet artiste à brigitte
perdant et on n'a pas pu vraiment
attentif à ce qu'il dépasse au point de
vue artistique apparaît sur quoi il faut
se donner au projet de comment elle est
là justement vous avez absolument voulu
la faire venir le monde lui son avis
lundi c'est bien tenez
tu penses que tu ai souvent pensé basse
et du cinéma concerne plutôt les cahiers
du cinéma
donc je voulais justement que vous voyez
un petit bonus à fait car il ya un chant
et contre chant
oui c'est michel simon c'était un
contrepoint je sais pas si je serai
content mais n'a pas voulu venir le voir
d'où on a voulu vérifier si vous étaient
attentifs aux nouveaux artistes
dissidents ps verts qui font de la
peinture est permis leur radio aussi les
dissidents il veut se faire de la
peinture qui vise nécessairement qu'on
appelle commentant une nouvelle onde
riche câline
oui à 25 ans et les jeunesses
socialistes de l'ue vient de lui confier
la campagne de prévention sur le sida se
joue à peu près bien un intérêt réel
dans le dense qui se passe au lieu de sa
vie depuis longtemps
notamment en matière de rock de punk et
d'art
qu'on a quand même des fois j'ai eu un
groupe punk de 5,7 et idées au lit ouais
alors lui est devenu un groupe de
variétés d'ailleurs vidéo lui l'état
luboslav lui a confié une campagne de
prévention contre le sida
oui avec ce avec ses capotes à la même
fosse scellée faut quand même en parler
oui ou pas à oui biensur handrich
galinet jamais existé mais actuelle a
tellement pratiqué le procédé de
l'imposture que jean françois bizot nous
pardonnera sans doute cette supercherie
notre façon à nous de fêter les 100 ans
d'un journal à qui on a fait pas droit
de réponse dans le numéro 101 actuelle
maintenant jean françois bizot
[Musique]
manche
jean françois bizot ça fait du bien je
me paye non jean-françois ouais ça fait
du bien parce que en fait il faut savoir
que le premier concert en france jimmy
page
c'était une soirée de la chaussée et
alors c'était une époque où les soins
des chaussées t'avais remake en smoking
un peu pressés des appareils et une
chemise blanche et puis les filles en
robes longues
1 et puis deux mecs qui étaient en bas
d'un pilier en béton un site toujours
c'est vrai on a pillé en béton ou jouer
les épines
paris les trois câbles un ampli de
fortune et jouets en bois la pierre mais
tout s'est intéressée rectum en personne
ses actes l'evian méfiance aux kings et
les mecs en robe longue
ouais passé oui bah non il comprend les
bains 1 sur le 10e plus en plus sa
branche et scott en vieillissant jean
françois bizot jean françois bizot vous
êtes journalistes patrons de presse
fondateur d'actuels de nova de radio
nova
vous êtes écrivain il ya les déclassés
qui ressort en ce moment
[Musique]
et puis les années blanches donc tous
les deux chez grasset voilà et vous
publiez actuellement un livre qui
s'appelle un moment de faiblesse
[Musique]
alors serait dû s'appeler même pas mal
et pourtant ça fait mal puisque jean
françois bizot vous racontez votre
cancer un cancer de la vessie
je vous dit je sais pas si c'est mon
plus grand reportage
mais c'est mon plus long reportage bah
oui puisqu'il est pas finie et que en
fait on apprend dans cette aventure
on apprend une patience dont on ne peut
pas vous prévenir
on ne peut pas vous dire il va falloir
être patient parce que c'est
décourageant donc on vous dit oued en
trois mois tu vas voir il ya profiteront
pas de +47 y en a rajouté une couche on
va te greffe était proposée du ça va
être intéressant
il s'agit d'ailleurs vous dites
d'ailleurs le patient est impatient par
définition
alors on parle de reportages moi je
crois que c'est surtout de la
littérature je vais dire le début du
camp ge ge est barbouillé des dizaines
de céramique blanche du g2 mon pinceau
rupestres carmin vermillon fuchsia rose
pivoine rouge brun chaque pigments
afficher une consistance appartenant à
une peinture différentes mais jamais le
même rouge vous dit le rouge c'est rod
co moi je comparerais le bouquin au
tableau de munch qui s'appelle le cri ou
un tableau de bacon tu vois c'est c'est
comme ça c'est un peu comme ça ce
bouquin on m'a dit ben il est tout nu
sans être à poil
1 donc c'est une 3e lille est devenue sa
d'être un poil donc tu peux de publier
un parce que en fait parce qu'en fait le
con bascule du jour au lendemain dans
une autre société c'est à dire
vous qui connaissez le clubbing d'un
seul coup on a le vip pass gold de la
nouvelle société qui s'appelle le cancer
club
c'est une maladie qu'on pourrait me mais
si vous vouliez je pourrais vous la mi
mai c'est à dire c'est une manie comme
ça hein
et ça c'est 2 3 heures par jour pendant
un certain temps
c'est une maladie comme ça après les
injections de kant grid 1
c'est une maladie comme ça quand on a
mal ouais et ça fait mal alors il faut
qu on fait ça on a pas mal d'ailleurs
alors on pas au début si la découverte
du mal justement des taches de sang sur
des toilettes verte
ça se passe en inde alors ya deux
solutions soit c'est la bilharziose zinc
est une maladie qu'on peut choper dans
les pays exotiques c'est des petites la
miba soit ce que ça qu'il soit si le
cancer est en fait malheureusement le
diagnostic
c'est le cancer vous revenez à paris
vous passer sur le billard le
chirurgiens retirent dites-vous une
tumeur de la taille d'un d'un quart d'un
paquet de daniela lui reproche une balle
de talc pour un traitement que vous sous
100 mille vannes vous la l'attraper en
finition claire blais l'attraper en
fumant je pense que c'est un cancer qui
présente l'inconvénient de ne pas être
déclarés sur le paquet club donc on
travaille dessus
c'est pas les poumons c'est la vessie
alors évidemment le chirurgien vous au
père et puis a pris vous dis moi j'ai
tout raclée 1 j'ai enlevé le plus
possible mais je suis pas apte il a il
arrive que l'herbe repousse et donc
c'est la signaux que c'est pas terrible
il a promis que la chimio ouais c'est
une guerre et la csd
du voyage dans le monde de la douleur
puisque peas et devient un calvaire à ce
moment là les civils c'est un plaisir
qui devient un calvaire c'est chiant
voilà les limaces géantes c'est quoi les
lits mazet entre les humains les limaces
jantes c'est un truc qui se passe quand
on a été opéré de cette partie du corps
où ils appellent ça des séries 6 4 est
souvent c'est des chutes des scarlets et
en fait c'est quand même pour les mecs
comme nous un truc assez curieux observé
quoi parce que en fait on se retrouve là
c'est bouché donc un plaisir de la
douleur et puis il faut expulser un truc
elle qui passe par un conduit qui n'a
pas été prévue demain à la bonne taille
quito avec l'as tu vois tu lâches un
petit tuyau là comme ça et puis pouf
ils sont une menace une masse oui bon
bah on va dire les choses comme ça c'est
super drôle en fait en exposition dans
les hôpitaux les ex mari l'ont lu à la
cantine
je vais charline est devant une forêt
tout en redonnant très difficiles à
expulser sa journée il sort après lequel
fait très mal
voilà ça fait mal à chaque fois et puis
peut y en avoir 50 cases elle habite en
charpie il faut dire il faut dire les
choses avaient une sonde dans le canal
de l'urètre et alors il ya une pression
assez gore il ya dans votre bouquin ce
serait terrible c'est un soir vous menez
un soir brûlé brûlé alors les médecins
viennent les infirmières viennent ils
voulaient sur les pendant des heures
vous dites je vote tan asie à ce moment
là je vous dis pas ce que je crée mes
chiottes et je prononcer le nom de
l'homme politique menu
qui porta longuement bretons eux ce halo
1 et c'était ça m'aidait votre façon de
vous défouler à ce n'est d'ailleurs
jeudi couvert finalement que d'un des
meilleurs combats contre la douleur
c'est de manifester en gros donc c'est
de prendre le nom du médecin qui tartas
du parc se pointent vers joue avec un
appui aux comme ça pour vous mettre un
truc machin tout petit mois du prince un
jeu pas été doté par la nature et donc
illégales
et bien il faut manifester parce quand
on manifeste ça mobilise le cerveau donc
prendre du médecin sur une même tombe du
bon et on fait du bon et de file du
front ça l'eau bibeau et de fibres
aident cède je vais quatre fois le
comprendre ouais ils voulaient sur les
comme ça pendant pendant toutes les non
ils ne peuvent rien
non à un moment ils s'aperçoivent que la
sonde est trop gonflé mais ils peuvent
rien ils s'élèveront de situation ils
sont trois pour 25 personnes
ça va pas ce [ __ ] ils sont trois pour
25 personnes et chaque chambre
chaque endroit c'est glisse à 15 minutes
de soins ouais donc tu sonnes et il faut
que le temps d'arriver et pierrick soin
d'établir que toi toi t'as vu juste mal
mais autres mois pour leur change à
1,1002 cher ouais voilà alors évidemment
là vous vous donner des détails qui sont
malheureusement vrai quoi c'est à dire
qu'à ce moment là tu as le prépuce
extrêmement gonfler le gland marbré et
alors il ya un mélange comme ça sous le
prépuce de de crem
les opportunistes via les opportunités
des maladies opportunistes faisait des
champignons par exemple et et vous dites
je n'avais jamais vécu en tête à tête
un spectacle personnel aussi navrant
c'est à dire que vous êtes navré en fait
de voir l'état de votre sexe c'est vrai
que je suis la raye pas ce que je peux
pas le montrer en plus donc
déjà ça sénat vent pouvant servir
donc ça c'est navrant je me demande ce
que c'est après donc je t'emmerde ans
quand je vous rassure
et puis oui et vous dit jean-françois la
baisse est impossible dit sans fard
écroulé alexandre y perdit son pouvoir
aujourd'hui avec new way
vous avez plus droit d'alcool maintenant
mais bon je vais rien empêché way la
drogue non on voit rien empêché train
partie du deal dans le livre d'ailleurs
j'assume mais j'assume très très
fortement le cannabis thérapeutique
ouais que j'avais quitté pendant dix ans
également vous dit le cannabis est
devenue un tic donc j'arrête et puis
vous reprenez pour des raisons
thérapeutiques
oui je peux dire pourquoi l'ayant vécu
et ça m'a beaucoup surpris j'y croyais
pas oui j'y croyais pas pour situer un
peu de tout niveau et j'ai fait ce choix
est en fait un pénis est les sautes
d'humeur et même les produits qui sera
sûrement violent et
sarr construisait l'appétit par contre
et 3 juin dans toutes les drogues qu'on
a fait prendre
parce que finalement dans cette maladie
on ne sait prendre toutes les drogues
possibles imaginables qui ont que
dont aucune n'a même franchement de
plaisir je suis d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il
fallait publier ce bouquin on m'a dit
oui on m'a dit oui on m'a dit ça donne
la pêche
ouais alors je vais faire un bon et puis
ça fait bizarre parce que c'est je
ressens ce truc comme un livre écrit par
un possédé qui l'est pas moins et
comment ça va se passer maintenant
la suite des événements coeur du nez
pour terminer c'est tous les jours et
encore la chimio à venir baoum la chimio
c'est que c'est que la chimio c'est
variable pour les gens il ya dans le
chimio ya il ya le truc qui est chiant
c'est de l'imprévisibilité de du moment
on va être annulé
on est un ide et tout d'un coup on n'est
plus rien ouais on tient un journal à la
main la dota pour votre chaudière
journal facile à lire jean libération
bon un truc toujours pas prise de tête
du tout quoi bon la nuit tombe
aujourd'hui mardi est tombé non peut
rien faire donc ça c'est cheminots mais
le truc le plus marrant quand même et
dans les trucs marrants parce que je
pensais naïvement c'est quand même été
cloué comme ça tu vois ouais ouais genre
jésus christ en fin de ton tour
donc les tuer parce que on te prends ton
sens de la la on le fait circuler pour
préparer des nouvelles cellules de toi
même plutôt clonés parce que c'est un
traitement hyper moderne qui va très
bien et tout un tas d'autres trucs comme
ça
francette heures peut pas bouger titou
séchant les caisses qui fait chier quand
on peut pas bouger
bien joué voilà un vrai mec qui connaît
la vie et alors tu peux pas de gratter
donc évidemment tu t'aperçois souvent là
pendant sept heures du nombre de fois où
tu envie de te gratter invraisemblable
fugace à lui tout et tu cries venir
gratter et alors là il se passe un truc
c'est absolument terrible c'est que les
autres ne savent pas te gratter ça peut
être une fille tu te dise avait 12 ou
pas il s'était relevé
elle prétend avoir regardé se dit elle
tape tellement tordu le nez que tu sens
plus rien pour le moment
société reed nadine vous avez connu ce
genre de maladie j'imagine oui avec mon
mari mais votre mail c'est pourquoi il
n'avait pas de cancer il avait dû tous
les problèmes que vous avez décrit en
partie il n'avait pas de cancer mais il
a fait de l'emphysème ce que tu m'as
être un site très très difficile à gérer
et mais il était d'un courage comme vous
monsieur extraordinaire âge ça en public
depuis la lâcheté c'est dans les
chiottes
jean françois bizot un moment de
faiblesse
et c'est grâce et mais la mézière
j'en reçois je laissais aller vous
coucher merci en tous les cas d'avoir
été avec nous courage bon ça va c'est
déjà passé ça je suis redevenu a lâché
je peux m'en aller
[Musique]